on a toujours envie et on sera toujours
séduit hallyday
[Musique]
mais la fête nationale je vous souhaite
aussi bonne fête parce que vous allez
voir bientôt 25 ans dans les prochains
jours ouais un quart de siècle ça a été
bien remplie j'espère que ça va être
tout aussi bien remplie le prochain la
fête nationale du québec ça pour vous
une double connotation votre
anniversaire sein du québec
webb un moment merck intense un talent
avec bien peur que georges voit le jour
le 1er juillet alex perrin que la
gestation est de la vente et finalement
je suis juste entre les deux faits que
mots j'aime / pensé que j'aurais pu les
lieux puis qu'il faut qu'ils fassent un
peu la séparation de les deux trilogies
a pris un départ imminent mobilité de
l'epic apparemment quel serait votre
choix pour que vous aimez autant mis mon
la chanson québécoise
oui je pense que l'amour de la langue
pour moi c'est indéniable je pense qu'il
ya tout un travail aussi de vouloir
rassembler les générations c'est cette
semaine je vais aller faire un spectacle
dans une résidence à québec puis les
histoires à prendre le temps de bien
prononcer les mots c'est quelque chose
que la population de plus vieillissante
chéri beaucoup plus point de vue des
jeunes bien c'est de pouvoir entrer un
vocabulaire un peu plus moderne se jouer
avec des anglicismes à l'intérieur donc
c'est de bien prononcer un journal qui
est très ressemblant votre parcours
m'impressionne beaucoup parce que vous
avez 25 ans bretons mais quand même deux
albums à votre actif vous avez commencé
[Musique]
12h07 inspiration pour apprendre le
métier à caen 16 ans mais je pense que
c'est comme tout le monde une passion il
pour avoir le goût de s'améliorer il
faut vraiment aimer ce qui bougeait très
reconnaissant de mon prof de guitare
lots secondaires monsieur la pierre qui
était tout cas un personnage un monsieur
qui physiquement ressemblait beaucoup à
albert einstein
donc il y avait vraiment et déplacés
c'est quand même il est impressionnant à
regarder et puis quand ils trippent
toute sa moumoute suivait secondaire 4
secondes à 5 j'ai appris la guitare avec
je pensais tout mais pause du dîner
assis da prince instruments puis je pars
tu sais que mon bagage puis aujourd'hui
je fais ça pour gagner ma vie fait que
je suis vraiment reconnaissant de ce que
professeur le facilement vous avez gardé
à longueuil il a dit au cégep édouard
montpetit moi vous êtes un amoureux de
l'histoire vain mot vos textes sont
riches mais vous avez décidé d'abord
donner vos études parce que votre
carrière à vraiment décoller rapidement
ça doit être un choix déchirant quand
même oui vraiment mais je suis content
du choix que j'ai fait parce que je
pense que je t'en guerre qui aime être
sur le terrain puis les rencontres que
j'ai fait avec des professionnels dans
mon métier sont aussi inspirante puis
c'est des gens qui connaissent beaucoup
de choses quand même type de pouvoir
voyager à travers le monde pour faire ma
musique qui sait que ce soit en france
ou nunavut où c'est partout au québec
évidemment
donc acheté une école ou si le ladite
tournée sur un texte que tout va bien
tout va bien parce que vous avez du bac
s qui le gouvernement en 2020 lors de la
fête nationale vous avez un macaron en
contre la loi 21 sur la laïcité il a pas
fait l affaire du premier ministre n'a
en soi le goût vraiment rapport qui vous
a critiqué quelques comment vous avez
vécu cet épisode ça m'a choqué parce que
je me suis rendu compte que j'ai pris un
chemin qui vaut vraiment axé sur la
confrontation
même si humainement c'est un gars qui
aime rassemblé maintenant important et
en tant que peuple même si une majorité
qui est d'accord avec des lois de quand
même prendre un moment pour écouter la
minorité qui subissent fixant au centre
de ces décisions là bas je vous écoute
parler là est ce qu'un jour on pourrait
avoir aimé la vidéo d'où la politique je
pense que oui je pense que oui parce que
si ça fait tellement partie de moi de
voir rencontrer des gens d'être sur le
terrain depuis
moi quand je t'attends à montréal-nord
de cette année j'étais content de voir
que ça mange en hiver un mauvais le nom
de quoi ça parle
puis c'est quoi les dossiers chauds puis
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour que
cette la culture québécoise
appartiennent à tous les québécois peu
importe leur couleur peu importe leurs
quartiers classés de donner justement un
sentiment d'appartenance
il faut
bongrain poisson d'un filet social voilà
vous ouvrez la porte lorsque milleville
haut doubs se présenteraient par exemple
aux prochaines élections provinciales
non mais je voyais très vocal parce que
j'ai j'ai mon parti
je vais supporter ok mais je pense que
ça va être bien d'orange la troisième
quatrième trio est habitué mais je
suppose souvent pendant les pauses
vous avez une chanson sur le roc est
alors on se quitte là dessus touchant 96
si j'ai pas connu 83,5 euros soit une
belle finale de la coupe stanley merci
ses livrables ses plats piloter je
m'ennuie des eaux jour et peut dépasser
[Musique]